hace pocos meses cuando hablamos por
primera vez de reacciones ha sido base
vemos como la lluvia ácida podía
derretir la cara de una estatua que es
mejor que derretir tu cara
aunque algunos ácidos pueden hacer así
que considera te afortunado la lluvia
ácida se forma cuando el dióxido de
azufre emitido por la quema de
combustibles fósiles reacciona con agua
en el aire para formar ácido sulfúrico
cuando la lluvia ácida estaba en su peor
momento en los años 80 y 90 era el azote
de las cristinas corrientes de agua en
toda europa y américa del norte algunos
ríos y arroyos quedaron completamente
desprovistos de algas y peces en montana
donde yo vivo vimos bastante lluvia
ácida también como lo puede atestiguar
esa estatua pero curiosamente los ríos y
arroyos aquí nos sufrieron los mismos
horribles efectos que en otros lugares
este lo que estoy parado ahora es el río
claro form permanece relativamente ileso
por la lluvia ácida de hecho cuando el
agua que lo alimentaba tenía un ph de
4.5 el río seguía siendo básico este es
un gotero lleno de ácido sulfúrico
diluido considerado un modelo para la
lluvia ácida y esto es solo agua
destilada con un indicador de ph que la
azul cuando es neutra o básica y la
tornará rosa así es al menos un poco
ácidas veamos cuánto ácido se necesita
para hacer nuestra agua destilada un
poco ácida agregamos una gota
wow ya es rosa muchachos ya es rosa una
gota pero intentemos lo mismo con el
agua del río veamos cuántas gotas se
necesitan antes de que cambie yo solo
solo lo estoy echando ahí lo estamos
obteniendo está empezando a suceder
ahora ahí está es una especie de mitad y
mitad tengo una transición de mitad y
mitad después de cinco o seis o siete
gotas fueron muchas más si ni siquiera
ha cambiado completamente agregamos un
poco más un poco más ahí vamos ahora esa
ciudad por qué pasó esto es porque este
río está protegido por piedra caliza que
es carbonato de calcio que está presente
a lo largo de todo el sistema del río la
lluvia ácida disuelve el carbonato de
calcio de la piedra caliza el río
arrastra el carbonato y actúa como un
amortiguador natural una solución
amortiguador a resiste a los cambios en
su ph cuando se le agrega un ácido o una
base fuerte entonces la geoquímica del
clark fork explica por qué la lluvia
ácida no es
devastador aquí como lo es indicamos las
montañas adirondack de nueva york donde
no hay piedra caliza en la amortiguó
mienta es un tema importante en la
química amortigua más las albercas para
evitar que los químicos dañen nuestra
piel y amortigua más las bebidas
gaseosas para evitar que los
saborizantes ácidos dañen nuestros
dientes y tejidos incluso tenemos
amortiguadores en nuestra sangre para
mantener nuestro ph interno constante y
mantener nuestra célula saludable creo
que es importante aprender sobre algo
tan poderoso tú qué opinas
una solución amortiguador a es una
mezcla de un ácido débil más base
conjugada una base débil más su ácido
conjugado esto se llaman parece ácido
base débil en referencia a ácidos y
bases significa que sólo se disocian
parcialmente en realidad es su debilidad
lo que los convierte en excelentes
amortiguadores como no se disocian
completamente en el agua y el
amortiguador no disociado puede actuar
como un donador o como un receptor de
protones lo cual ayuda a neutralizar un
ácido o base fuerte que se agrega a la
solución en realidad todo se trata de
equilibrio por ejemplo cuando un ácido
levi's como el ácido acético se agrega
al agua una pequeña fracción se disocia
en sus iones constituyentes los acetato
y iones hidrógeno o protones hace poco
estaba perdiendo una gran cantidad de
una solución como está en mi pescado
frito con papas el vinagre es solo una
solución al 5% de ácido acético pero la
reacción también es reversible y ahí es
donde entra el equilibrio digamos que
tenemos una solución 1 molar de ácido
acético para hacer que la solución sea
amortiguadora necesitamos aumentar la
concentración de la base con jugada de
ácido acético acetato
de acetato de sodio esa sería una buena
manera el acetato de sodio se disocia
completamente proporcionando así muchos
iones acetato para ver cómo funciona
esto en la práctica agreguemos
suficiente de esa sal para hacer una
solución no molar
sabemos cuánto ácido y cuánto acetato
ponemos pero lo importante es el ph y
para determinar eso tenemos que saber
cuántos protones hay en una tabla raíz
nos ayuda a tener un seguimiento de todo
la reacción r que nos interesa aquí por
supuesto es la disociación del ácido
acético podemos ignorar el sodio del
acetato de sodio pues aunque se quedará
es sólo un ión espectador que no
participará en ninguna reacción nuestra
solución contiene concentraciones
iniciales de un ácido 1 molar y un
acetato 1 molar todavía no hemos formado
iones hidrógeno así que eso se queda en
cero por ahora no sabemos cuánto
cambiarán las concentraciones entonces
lo llamamos x el ácido pierde x y ambos
iones ganan x y nuestras concentraciones
en equilibrio
entonces 1 - x 1 x y simplemente x en
ese orden ahora sólo se ponen los
números en la fórmula de equilibrio
1.76 por 10 a la menos 5 pero cuando los
químicos trabajan con ecuaciones de
disociación para ácidos y bases le dan a
la guy cook la de equilibrio un hombre
especial la constante de disociación de
ácidos o bases el símbolo para este tipo
de constante de equilibrio es que para
un ácido okabe para una base así que se
usa la expresión de equilibrio para el
ácido acético y se pone el caa y las
concentraciones de equilibrio de la
tabla rayón con un poco de álgebra
simple se simplifica eso no parece
significado supongo que se podría llamar
simplificación pero son cuadráticas no
quiero hacer eso así que aquí hay un
pequeño truco para hacer eso mucho más
fácil de mirar el ácido acético es un
ácido realmente débil entonces sólo una
pequeña fracción se disocia lo que
significa que si sea súper pequeño si es
tan pequeño que después de redondear por
cifras significativas no cambia nuestra
respuesta en absoluto entonces por qué
no dejarlo de lado de modo que esa
primera equis para el guión hidrógeno
tiene más efecto porque está
multiplicando pero las otras dos
olvidemos que están ahí y veamos qué
sucede si volvemos a donde sustituimos
todos los números y simplemente quitamos
las dos equis que se suman y restan el
resto del problema se cancela dejando x
igual a 1 punto 76 por 10 a la menos 5
el resto es muy fácil con unas cuantas
teclas en la calculadora encontramos que
el ph es 4.754 pero aquí está la gran
pregunta qué pasa si tratamos de poner
el ph fuera de control el objetivo de un
amortiguador es resistir eso cierto se
agregó un ácido fuerte como por ejemplo
ácido clorhídrico a una concentración de
0.1 moles por litros a agua destilada el
ph cambiará muy rápidamente caerá
rápidamente si ahora estamos en 3 ph 3
no es un ambiente saludable para la
mayoría de los organismos ahora pensemos
en lo que le sucedería al ph con un
amortiguador aunque el ácido clorhídrico
sediciosa completamente en agua
liberando muchos iones hidrógenos cuando
se agrega una solución amortiguador a
con acetato el exceso de iones hidrógeno
se une a evoluciones acetato para formar
ácido acético por lo tanto ese ha sido
fuerte no puede afectar mucho el ph
porque se están usando los iones hidro
para neutralizar punto 0 1 molar de
ácido clorhídrico o más específicamente
punto 0 1 molar de h más la
concentración de acetato debe disminuir
0.01 moles por litro aumentando
simultáneamente la concentración de
ácido acético 0.01 moles por litro
eso nos deja con acetato puntos 99 molar
y 1.01 molar de ácido acético bueno el
ph se determina a partir de la
concentración de protones que está en
nuestra ecuación de equilibrio así que
resolvamos esto cuando sustituye es el
nuevo ácido acético las concentraciones
de acetato y el k
obtienes 1.80 por 10 a la menos 5 moles
por litro para la concentración de
protones que se traduce en un ph de
4.746 obviamente esto no es un gran
cambio a partir de 4.754 de hecho tuve
que llegar al cuarto dígito para ver el
cambio del ph lo que ni siquiera se
justifica si mezclas words de química
sobre cifras significativas pero tengo
que confesar el vinagre y el ácido
clorhídrico pueden hacer que las cosas
sean más fáciles de entender pero no son
exactamente relevantes en términos
en cambio quiero que veas cómo funciona
esto en el mundo real entonces
consideremos el sistema amortiguador del
río clyde form allí la reacción entre la
piedra caliza disuelta y la lluvia a
ciudad realmente ocurre unos pasos
primero es solvente carbonato de calcio
reacciona con los protones de la lluvia
ácida para formar iones calcio y
bicarbonato los iones de bicarbonato
tienen cada uno un hidrógeno mientras
haya protones disponibles los iones
bicarbonato pueden tomar un segundo
protón para convertirse en ácido
carbónico sin carga como puedes ver esta
reacción en cadena usa dos protones por
molécula de carbonato de calcio eso hace
que este proceso sea doblemente poderoso
y eso explica por qué el río claro
porque está resistente a la
acidificación pero por supuesto los
amortiguadores no son invencibles agrega
suficiente ácido o base e incluso la
mejor solución amortiguadora será
sobrepasada llamamos a ese umbral la
capacidad de amortiguador a de la
solución y lo determinamos en el
laboratorio usando indicadores de ph a
través de un proceso llamado titulación
anteriormente use un indicador de ph que
mostraba un ph
al volverse rosa pero hay muchos otros
indicadores cada uno con diferentes
colores y un ph diferente donde cambian
esto se llama el punto final del
indicador
aquí tenemos 100 mililitros de agua del
río a los que he agregado un indicador
de ph en realidad es una mezcla de dos
indicadores de th diferentes verde de
bromo cresol y rojo de metilo que
funcionan bien juntos para esta reacción
se mantendrá de color azul mientras
funciones bicarbonato estén ahí para
mantener el ph amortiguado por encima
del punto final del indicador de ph 4
esta cosa larga de vidrio es una buena
es para regular la salida de líquidos de
forma muy controlada mientras lleva la
cuenta de cuánto ha salido por el
momento contiene exactamente 25
mililitros de una solución de ácido
sulfúrico 0.10 molar lo que hay que
hacer es agregar el ácido muy lentamente
mientras se agita lo que estoy haciendo
con este agitador automático que está
bastante bien
y puedes hacerlo de varias maneras si
tienes una idea de cuánto puedes poner
puedes abrirlo y dejarlo salir pero yo
no sé así que solo voy a dejarlo gotear
muy lentamente
puedo girar lo ligeramente para hacer
que gotee
entonces estamos esperando ver si sucede
algún cambio y hay un pequeño cambio
pero ahora está retrocediendo entonces
nos estamos acercando
y lo que estoy haciendo ahora es que
estoy agregando menos de una gota a la
vez abriendo rápidamente la abertura de
la bureta de hecho puedo ver la reacción
que ocurre justo delante de mis ojos ese
hermoso y luego retrocede en este
momento es un azul más pálido que antes
lo cual es emocionante eso significa que
nos estamos acercando mucho estas son
las cosas que me emocionan sé que soy un
nerd o es casi blanco en este momento es
un poco rosa es púrpura así que o
hermoso
eso fue perfecto la solución ahora
permanece rosa lo que significa que he
agotado su capacidad de amortiguación y
el ph ha caído por debajo del punto
final del indicador el volumen en la
pipeta ahora es de 22.4 mililitros lo
que significa que usted 2.6 mililitros o
punto 0 026 litros de la solución ácida
la solución ácida es 0.1 molar así que
multiplicando estos números me dice que
use punto 0 0 026 moles de h2so4 el
ácido sulfúrico reacciona en una
reacción uno a uno con carbonato de
calcio entonces asumiendo que el
carbonato de calcio es el único
amortiguador en el agua los 100
mililitros de agua de río aquí también
deben contener punto 0 0 026 moles de
carbonato de calcio convirtiéndolo en
una solución de punto 0 026 molar o una
solución 2.6 mili molar soy un gran
admirador de proteger el medio ambiente
pero a veces es asombroso ver lo que
puede hacer la naturaleza para
protegerse a sí misma vivimos en un
mundo asombroso y no lo cambiaría por
nada
siquiera por martes